die lage in deutschland ist dramatisch
viele unternehmerinnen und unternehmer
sorgen sich um ihre zukunft viele
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher sind
jetzt schon schwerlich imstande die
kosten die sie wöchentlich monatlich
jährlich haben zu leisten bei der frage
wie wir dieses land mit energie mit
strom mit wärme versorgen können
brauchen zurzeit die köpfe die grünen
haben sich über die maßen angestrengt
jetzt wieder die fossilen energien in
deutschland voranzubringen und die
kohleverstromung wieder voranzubringen
heute ist die zweite alarmstufe beim
plan für gas ausgesprochen worden was
robert habe ich allerdings nicht macht
ist tatsächlich alle energetischen
alternativen zu prüfen und dazu zählt
natürlich der atomstrom diese atomstrom
ist durchaus betreiber die drei
atomkraftwerke sind weiterhin betreibt
war auch die die bereits abgeschaltet
wurden können reaktiviert werden
rechtliche argumente hinter denen man
sich versteckt sind völlig haltlos auch
die frage wo kriegt man die brennstäbe
her sind gerade zuletzt heute vom tüv
süd widerlegt worden also wenn robert
habeck über seinen schatten springen
würde und nicht so viel ideologie in
seiner energiepolitik walten lassen
würde dann würden wir in der frage wie
wir in den herbst gehen zum tag heute
deutlich besser dastehen mehr
interessant ist natürlich die
beobachtung dass wir immer sagt gesagt
bekommen von den damen und herren die
die korona politik oder jetzt die
energiepolitik exekutieren alles wird
sich ändern nichts wird bleiben wie es
war die welt nach krone und nach der
ukraine krieg wird anders sein als zuvor
und dennoch verharrt die beobachtung ist
ja richtig die grüne partei mit erna
berg an der spitze bisher bei diesem
dogma nicht rütteln am atomausstieg also
alles soll sich ändern aber das bitte
schön dich das ist natürlich
unvernünftig es wäre eine pointe der
geschichte wenn sie jetzt gerade die
grüne partei rückgängig machen würde was
und das muss ich natürlich schon
vorhalten was schwarz-gelb da mal ins
werk gesetzt also eine dem namen nach
dem namen nach konservative regierung
angegriffene stimmungs politikerin frau
merkel hat mitbekommen weit weit weg
hinten in japan ist etwas passiert ein
seebeben und weil deutschland ihn so
viel mehreren liegt müssen wir hier
jetzt die atomkraft schnell mal
abschalten gleiches ad hoc system
natürlich auch wir bei der aussetzung
der wehrkraft klarer und dem monster und
selbst war der auslöser dieses kopflose
sao tomé handeln ja die dinger gebaut
und schüttet heute noch kommen aber das
geht jetzt das hat diesen erstmal
letzten endes natürlich sagen muss also
die müssen jetzt mal schnellster im pott
kommen um einen fehler zu beheben den
wir also wir als cdu maßgeblich mit zu
verantworten haben und ich glaube nicht
dass heute eine energie oder ein
umweltminister wie er vorher hieß namens
altmaier dass eventuell ein kanzler
laschet heute sofort die atommeiler
wieder einstellen würde der wird sich
auch verein status quo zurückrufen also
china zurück beziehen also ich glaube
mit einer anderen regierung werden die
gleichen probleme da und dann würden
vielleicht heute die grünen sagen man
gucken was er darstellt jetzt wir sind
uns doch in der sache einig und wir
verurteilen robert habeck nicht für das
was andere regierungen vor jahren mal
entschieden haben es heute um die frage
wie fähig ist politik heute wie fähig
ist diese ampel regierung auf eine
aktuelle krise zu reagieren die dieses
land praktisch gegen die wand fahren
kann im herbst und im winter sie können
sich das also wir können uns das glaube
ich alle nicht vorstellen was uns hier
bevorsteht jetzt geht nicht nur darum
dass die heizung vielleicht aus ist oder
dass wer kalt duschen müssen es geht um
die funktionalität unserer gesamten
deutschen industrie also und das ist
dass während ihrer parade wacker chemie
sind noch eine sache fragen
zurückblicken haben wir gerade zurück
auf die zeit der union als
regierungspartei aber es gibt ja auch
eine eine wahrheit über die man auch
sprechen muss treffen russland die
sanktionen vielleicht gar nicht so stark
wie wir dachten oder wie die neue
regierung ist dachte wie ist jetzt
deutschland trifft wenn man jetzt auf
gas wieder schaut also nach den uns
vorliegenden informationen treffen
russland die sanktionen sehr sehr wohl
aber russland ist natürlich auch ein
staat der versucht wie können wir durch
diese krise da kommen und was können wir
alternativen auf die beine stellen und
am ende wird sich zeigen wer den
längeren atem hat
über sanktion betrifft also ich sie
werden langfristig wirken nicht
kurzfristig lösen man könnte natürlich
sagen zuvor den krieg beenden die es
nicht gegeben also ist das halte ich für
völlig richtig funktionieren das problem
das wir haben ist folgendes gas ist ein
wichtiger prozess stoff in der industrie
chemische industrie und wir haben als
zurzeit wir sind wieder sehr aktiv dabei
die automobilindustrie platz zu machen
durch verbrenner verboten ähnliches im
nächsten schritt machen wir die
chemische industrie
platini ist nicht mehr kostenmäßig
wettbewerbsfähig die wird den usa
produzieren und china produzieren die
standorte gibt auch schon dort gibt es
belege energie und bei uns nicht und das
ist nicht nur momentaner schock in
diesem winter sondern es gibt
strukturell an die substanz und sie
haben vorhin so schön waren vorgerechnet
die einkommen pro kopf wo haben wir eine
gute einkommen pro kopf in der
automobilindustrie und der
chemieindustrie und diese beiden
industrien verlieren da haben wir einen
massiven wohlstandsverlust das ist
völlig ausgeblendet und vor dem
hintergrund eines dieser dramatik bin
ich bei ihnen dann müsste nicht durch
die atomkraftwerke länger laufen lassen
und die 3 die jahre funktionsfähig sind
weil das vom paar wochen ausgeschaltet
wurden wieder anschalten das ist der
einen und der nächste asbecker das land
scheint es nicht nur ein schalter das
heißt er ist das erste jahr brauchen
oder die brennstoffe zugesagt sorgen
jetzt dritter aber es lohnt sich das zu
tun und lieblingsorte regent der mir
dieser nutzen würde perspektive schon
wasserstoff zu erzeugen wenn man die
energiewende wirklich machen will
braucht man der wasserstoff um in der
zeit wo geht's weiter was zumal es
werden liegend aber das ist wie gesagt
wegen ideologie nicht möglich ein aspekt
nur wie hat sich dann halten wir haben
noch nichts zu essen so ist weil die
nahrungsmittelindustrie im hohen maße
von gas abhängt also becker also der
bäcker anhalt ist dramatisch die
situation ist dramatisch weil dies in
jeder hinsicht dramatisch wir haben wir
haben weltweit auch noch probleme haben
weltweit das hungerproblem dazu müssten
wir alles tun um die
nahrungsmittelproduktion in deutschland
zu fördern machen wir nicht weil wir
legen viel über die flächen stellen wir
müssten dringend alles tun um jede
kilowattstunde sparen sagte habeck ja
auch machen wir nicht weil atomkraft ist
yahoo
aber trotzdem finde ich jetzt kleinen
kleinen anspruch her dass doch etwas zu
apokalyptisch jetzt also sie haben
gesagt wir machen jetzt die
chemieindustrie kaputt also basf ist die
grösste industrie und energieunternehmen
chemieunternehmen der welt meines
wissens also das wird jetzt nicht platt
von diesem halben versagen chinesische
die gesamte die gesamte
automobilindustrie wird auch nicht platt
gemacht wie wird sich teilweise
transformieren ich hoffe euch auch neu
erfinden also nach einem halben jahr ist
nicht die kindliche beiden tragenden
hinterhergehen und adressen machen
einfach denken dass nach dem halben jahr
wieder belege haben wir haben auf dauer
keine billige energie mehr das modell
war billiges gas aus russland versorgt
die industrie hier das ist es nicht mehr
wenn wir allen diese flüssiggas haben
wenn sie überhaupt kriegen wenn die
amerikaner also noch nicht weil mit ihm
selber teuro preis aber die von ihr
nicht mehr wenn du musst mir ja kommen
das ist klimaschädlich hoch zehn das
heer zu transferieren und wenn es hier
so teuer es ist ein kostenfaktor ist ein
halbes jahr wenn ich jetzt der ceo von
basf wäre ich habe eine stadt in den usa
ich habe riesen start und entschieden
das ist der größte standort nicht in
ludwigs haben sondern in china und ich
frage mich wo ließ die zukunft als ich
die zukunft nicht in dem land mit den
höchsten strompreise schon vor monaten
soll im vorfeld hatten das ist einfach
weg das ist das so ein schuss ins knie
und dafür finde ich ist er habe extrem
entspannt betroffen in die kamera und
sagt ich bin ja nicht dran schuld was
nicht stimmt bei dem drummer thomas steg
nicht gemacht ohne grün er guckt aber
immer so mit so einem schmollmund er
kommt ehrlich und 1 der welt es ist
leipzig halle mit den grünen ist das ist
ich hab' ich bin eine
leistungsgesellschaft groß geworden ich
kann nur mit intelligenten menschen muss
anfang halbwegs an der haw kind wenig
intelligenten habe
seit die medien ja ihr wisst was darum
läuft das ist da fragst du dich manchmal
wie im normalen leben zurechtkommen
würden bei mir die probezeit für einige
politiker nicht spiele für drinnen ich
schätze einige von uns sagen doch ich
kann gerne namen aufzählen aber das
würde ich meine jungs sprengen die
süddeutsche du wieder die
süddeutsche zeitung schrieb heute habe
ich mache zurzeit alles perfekt also die
meinungen gehen wirklich sehr
auseinander und nochmal ich ich teile
ihre diagnose doch erstellter ich will
jetzt gar nicht sagen wir machen alles
richtig machen das meiste falsch machen
vieles falsch aber ich glaube dass diese
apocalyptic wenn wir uns da
hineinsteigern jetzt uns auch nicht
weiter bringt katastrophen treten dann
noch schneller einen gefestigten
andersrum
wir müssen jetzt panik haben damit wir
noch wir müssen jetzt panik haben damit
es im herbst nicht so schlechter geht
und ich sage ihnen wir haben noch nicht
genug das ist ja panik verbreiten ein
normal ich habe vorhin gesagt wir haben
in diesem mai 22 so viel gas verbrannt
für strom erzeugt wie noch nie in der
geschichte deutschlands das ist ein
steak nach darstellung noch ein
statement von mir also es ist nicht so
dass die apokalypse uns von heute auf
morgen überrollt in allen
lebensbereichen das ist nicht der fall
aber es geht stück für stück für stück
und zwar seit jahren wir haben keine
fachkräfte mehr wir haben keine
arbeitskräfte mehr unternehmen können
nicht mehr arbeiten weil ihnen die leute
fehlen die situation ist dran faktisch
corona ist noch immer nicht überwunden
in den bilanzen der unternehmen gestern
gerade erst sagte eine gute er braucht
17 jahre um die verluste aus kohle
wieder zu erarbeiten das ist
unvorstellbar und das wissen wir auch
manchmal da mit hörten im mund und
realisieren was eigentlich gramm los
also ihre partei hat die guten jahre
nicht genutzt das land wiesenfest omar
ist ist da werden sogar zustimmen das
herstellen hier stellt er meinte dass
panik jetzt auch wichtig ist um den
ernst der lage nicht erhebungen bei der
politik muss haben wir die kreierung
sorry sie waren daran aber nicht ich
möchte keine panik bei den zuschauern
verbreiten oder erfolg aber die
regierung muss zu handeln als kommt der
schlimmste fall war dann kann sie jetzt
noch die richtigen maßnahmen greifen
fernseher stelle ich habe jetzt panik
nach dieser sendung na ja sie mit der
polizei überhaupt machen sagen wenn die
iren dem ich jetzt nicht ihren job macht
und dann haben wir da taten bitteren
also einig trifft man keine guten
entscheidungen aber man soll jeder
realistisch man sollte realistisch die
lage bewerten und danach handeln und das
schlimme ist dass wir gerade in fragen
der strom energieversorgung zum teil
auch ideologisch regiert werden ja und
eben nicht objektiv und das wäre gerade
in so einer krise
war ein crooner kann man immer das
stichwort der ganze instrumentenkasten
muss auf dem tisch der muss ja auf dem
tisch liegt ihr nicht auf den tisch so
es ist das ist das problem so hat mich
eingeladen weil hier bürger bin ja dann
hört doch auf die wir sollten wenn bei
mir war es nicht funktioniert der firma
und fluch rede ist und es bringt nichts
ja und dann hat man meinen stiefel im
hintern damit funktioniert und man redet
öfter oder mal überlegt sie was es gibt
konsequenzen
ja natürlich natürlich was das ist doch
dieser unterschied der einen wahnsinnig
macht wo man sagt hier konstruiert
treiben was willst